في جديد قضيه الفنان سعد المجرد التي شغلت
الوسط الفني قدم لمجرد استئنافا على الحكم
الصادر بحقه بالسجن ست سنوات حسب ما اعلن
محاميه ومصر قضائي اليوم قال محامي المغني
لوكاله
تاكيدا على براءته
هي المذنبه فهي من ذهبت الى هناك هذه
الفكره تعتبر الدليل براءه بالنسبه لمعجبي
مشهور متهم في قضيه اعتداء واغتصاب على
الفضائل الالكترونيه تشكلت المحاكم
الافتراضيه وكل يدلي برايه ودفاعاته
والحديث هنا عن قضيه الفنان سعد المجرد
لكن البعض رفض تماما فكره الدفاع المجرد
حتى ان الناشطين وضعوا قائمه باسماء ابرز
المشاهير المغاربه الذين اعلنوا عن
تعاطفهم معه لم انتشرت عده نظريات للحاله
النفسيه للمدافعين عن المشاهير المتهمين
بالاعتداءات منهم انهم لا يستطيعون
التفريق بين الفن الذي يقدمه المشهور وبين
السلوكياته اخرون
ويعتبرونهم يختبئون من الحدث الصادم
ويحملون الضحيه المسؤوليه كحاله فرديه في
المجتمع ومع انتشار مثل هذه القضايا بين
مشاهير الفن والرياضه والسياسه يرى
مدافعون ان الضحايا اعضاء في عصابات
متخصصه في استدراج النجوم والمشاهير
لابتزازهم او تدم استقبلهم الفني او
الرياضي
في نهايه عام 2017 اطلقت الممثله
الامريكيه اليسا ميليانو هاشتاج ميتو
للكشف عن اسماء المتحرشين ومرتكبي جرائم
الاعتداء الجنسيه منذ ذلك الحين وخرجت
العديد من القضايا منهم المنتج الامريكي
الذي حكم عليه بالسجن لمده 16 عاما ضمن
قضيه اتهامه بالاعتداء على 90 فنانه في
قضيه شرف هزت الوسط الفني منذ ست سنوات
هناك ايضا الممثل كافيني الحائز على جائزه
الاوسكار الذي يواجه الدعاءات باعتداءه
جنسيا على فتى قبل 36 عاما ويواجه ايضا
خمساتها منفصله بالاعتداء الجنسي في
بريطانيا حتى الممثل مورجان فريمان الذي
اعتزل التمثيل بعد تكرار اتهامات التحرش
الجنسي وسوء السلوك من ثماني سيدات ايضا
الممثله
اليسا ارجنتو ادعى عليها الممثل الشاب
جيمي بنت بالتحرش به جنسيا وهو في سن 17
عاما وفي عالم الرياضه طالت مزاعم
الاغتصاب البرتغالي رونالدو والبرازيلي
نيمار ماسون واخرهم المغربي اشرف حكيمي
وغيرهم بالرغم من براءه بعض اللاعبين من
مثل هذه الاتهامات الا ان بعضهم ودينوا
ودخلوا السجن لفتره ليست بالقصيره ابرزهم
كان ادم جونسون لاعب مانشستر سيتي الاسبق
[موسيقى]
طيب في الاستوديو ينضم لنا المحامي باسم
ظاهر باسم يسعد صباحك منورنا في الاستوديو
اهلا طيب بين الجدل الكبير الذي حصل بين
مؤيد ومعارض قضايا الاغتصاب في القانون
الدولي كيف يتم النظر فيها قانونيا طبعا
نحن انون يعني الاوانين ما فينا نقول
بالقانون الدولي فقط كل دوله الى قانون
بطبيعه الحال ولكن العامل الاساسي لهذه
الجريمه هو عامل الكونسنت عامل الرضا هل
فينا نثبت انه في رضا ولا لا هلا بنهايه
الامر دخول شخص معين على منزل شخص لا يعطي
الرضا بشكل تلقائي هل كانت ساعه متاخره
طبعا لا يمكن للاعتبار انه انا اعطيت
الرضا بشكل طلقات اتفضل
عم بيقولوا انه الفتاه التي تعرضت لاغتصاب
كما ادعت من قبل سعد لمجرد انه هي كانت
اصلا في غرفه الفندق يعني ما هي الخط
الفاصل او الحدود انه نحن نقول هذا اغتصاب
او هذا رضا طرفين صاروا مع بعض في نفس
الغرفه اذا تسمحي لي ست نادين سريعا جدا
قبل ما اجاوب لا يجوز لالنا نحنا كمجتمع
او كميديا او كسوشيال ميديا انه نحكم على
الضحيه او على
[موسيقى]
المعتدي او لا جدلي معدل قبل ما نثبت انه
هو ضحيه او معتدله يعني في كثير عالم متهم
خلينا نقول متهم طبعا شكرا للتوضيح
القانوني
بهيدي الحاله هيدا شي خطر جدا ونحن
كمحامين بنشوفها بجرائم اخف بكثير وقتها
بتبلش تنهال الاتهامات قبل ما يكون في حكم
قضائي مبرم
نهائي بعض الاحيان يعني بتؤدي للانتحار
وشفنا كثير حالات عالميا طبعا ادت
للانتحار سلبريتي صغيره بس لانه اتهم هذا
الشخص مش اكثر وكل الشتائم يلي نهايت عليه
بالسوشيال ميديا وقبل الميديا لذلك
التوعيه بهذا الاطار مهمه جدا لانه حياه
الانسان مهمه ان كانت الضحيه او المتهم
ونحترم القانون ونحترم القضاء ونخلي عنا
حكم مبرم خيره النهار يعني قبل ما نبلش
نحن نعطي اتهامات ونكون المحامي والقاضي
والجنه التحقيق والشرطه يعني محاكمه
استمرت سبع سنوات مجرد لكونه متهم شفنا
قضايا ممثله كريستيانو رونالدو نيمار
اخرها اشرف حكيمي كذلك في فرنسا هل ان
القضيه طويله بسبب الجدل حولها لانه
المتهمه مشهور ام ان الدلائل صعبه في هكذا
وقائع
البدايه بالقانون نحن يعني لو كان القانون
ابيض واسود وسريع اللي احنا خلينا نضب
اغراضنا ونروح على البيت نحن والاوضات
تشتغل عنا مثل ما الماشينز عم تشتغل عن
غيرنا كل القضيه
ولازم ننبش على الدلائل ولازم ننبش على
الظروف يعني راح اعطي مثل اذا هذا الشخص
له علاقات سابقه مع الشخص مع مع الضحيه
المتهم مع الضحيه وفي علاقات حميمه الى ما
هنالك على فترات سنوات الى ممكن تكون
دلائل انه هذا الشخص ولكن منا قاطعه يعني
باي وقت انا اللي بدي اقوله وهيدي توعيه
كتير مهمه للنساء باي وقت المراه ممكن ان
ترفض هذه العلاقه حتى لو اخر دقيقه ارد لا
طبعا طب يعني خليني كمان افهم يعني هل
التعريف القانوني للاغتصاب غير واضح
بالنسبه لنا كعرب يعني المساله ليست تفكر
فقط الاكراه في العلاقه بل ممكن سوء
استخدام السلطه الذكوريه من الرجل للمراه
ممكن يكون هلا الرضا يعني ممكن يكون فيزيك
الابيوز ويعني استعمال القوه ضد المراه
الجسديه ممكن التعنيف المعنوي ممكن
التعنيف بسيكولوجي يعني النفسي ببعض
الاحيان وممكن نقطه جيده جدا اساءه
استعمال مركز معين
للحصول على تقديمات من هذا بهذا الاطار
للاسف وشفناها كثير بالولايات واحده طبعا
يعني هلا ممكن هذا الجرم يدخل بالهراسمنت
ممكن يدخل اصوات ممكن يكون يعني يا تحرش
يا اعتداء جنسي يا اغتصاب هون بتفرق بين
دوله ودوله الدفنشن يعني التعريف لهذا
الجرم كيف بيكون طيب المحامي المحامي سعد
المجرد كان معنا قبل في مقابله مع الصباح
العربيه وقال انه المحكمه والقاضي اخذ
باقوال لورا الضحيه هل هناك قانونيا تعاطف
مع الضحيه
القانونيه
من من يعني من اللي بنشوفه لا مش بالضروره
يكون في تعاطف مع مع الضحيه لقلك ليش لانه
الحكم
على المتهم بالاغتصاب هو حكم اعدام يعني
مش حكم اعدام بس هو حكم اعدام معنوي حتى
لو مكان السنتنس هي
معنا
اجتماعي هذا الشخص يعني صعب يصير عنده اي
علاقه طبيعيه من بعد هذا الحكم وبالتالي
تؤخذ بجديه هلا بقانون العمل مثلا يتم
التعاطف مع الموظف اكثر من الامبل بهذه
الحاله لانه يعني اخره النهار بتفرق على
موضوع ماده صغير ولكن هون عم نحكي موضوع
كتير مهم وبالتالي القاضي يعرف ويعلم بشكل
قاطع انه ممكن يكون عنا ضحيتين بدل ضحيه
بهذه الحاله وبالتالي لازم يحمي الطرفين
لازم يحكي يحمي حقوق المتهم وطبعا المدعية
عم ببرروا الاختصاب انه صار تحت تاثير
مخدرات تحت تاثير كحول مثلا هل هذا
التعامله وقضائيا وقانونيا مختلف عن انه
شخص سوي يقوم بالاغتصاب للامانه بعده دول
بتختلف يعني ببعض الدول الاكشن اللي بتشدد
العقوبه
لانه يعتبر يعني المشتري اعتبر انه بمجرد
ما هو سمح لحاله يكون بموقف معين تعاطى
المخدرات تعرض الشخص الاخر
ويعني ليه اخطر ببعض الدول الاخرى بالعكس
بتخفضها ليش لانه بتقول انه هذا الشخص
وتصميم ومش 100% هو ناوي يعمل هذا الموضوع
فمنشوف عالميا في اختلاف بين الدوله
والاخرى شكرا جزيلا لك المحامي الدولي
باسم ظاهر شكرا بس